j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public consacré à la campagne
présidentielle américaine moins d'un an
avant une élection qui devrait nous
proposer un match retour entre Joe Biden
et Donald Trump le président sortant
démocrate pensait que ce serait facile
de battre de nouveau un Trump qui fait
figure des bouventail pour beaucoup
d'Américains mais selon les sondages le
match est très très loin d'être plié
Marion
Vigreux une élection 2027 aux allures de
revanche pour Donald Trump nous devons
les faire S tire du bureau oval et un
probable duel Biden Trump qui fait déjà
la une des journaux aux États-Unis et
pourtant un an de l'élection ils sont
une dizaine à briguer le poste côté
républicain les débats s'enchaînent
autant que les abandons de ser Rivau de
Donald Trump ont jeter l'éponge le
sénateur Tim Scott et l'ancien
vice-président Mike pence les autres
candidats encore en lise bataille dur
pour déloger le favori Donald Trump
malgré ses ennuies judiciaires ses
meetings font le plein côté démocrate
pas d'adversaire sérieux pour Joe Biden
avec une primaire quasi jouée d'avance
mais le président a un handicap de poids
son âge 80 ans selon un sondage publié
par le New York Times 71 % des
Américains le juge trop vieux pour être
président parmi eux 54 % d'électeurs
démocrates je pense qu'il est un peu
trop vieux pour représenter notre
population actuelle et notre pourcentage
de
démographie je pense que Joe Biden et
même Donald Trump ont peut-être un peut
dépasser l'âge de me conduire vers
l'avenir que je veux voir à un an de
l'élection les deux hommes sont en tout
cas au coude à coude dans les sondages
44 % d'intention de vote pour Joe Biden
48 % pour Donald Trump mais avec un
candidat indépendant Robert Kennedy
junior qui pourrait venir jouer les
troubles faites quant au calendrier les
primaires démocrates et républicaines
auront lieu de janvier à juin dans
chaque État suivi des conventions qui
désigneront le candidat de chaque parti
avant l'élection du 5 novembre et une
investiture prévue le 20 janvier
2025 Joe Biden est-il forcément le
meilleur candidat du camp démocrate
comment Donald Trump est-il redevenu le
favori des sondages on en débat avec
Anne desine bonsoirons bienvenue vous
êtes professeur des universités juriste
et auteur euh de ce livre les États-Unis
et la démocratie publié aux éditions
l'armatan Alexis Pichard bonsoir et
bienvenue chercheur en civilisation
américaine Armel charriier bonsoir
bienvenue à vous éditorialiste
internationale à France 24 spécialiste
en géopolitique stratégie et défense on
est également en duplexe avec Olivier
pyon avocat au barreau de Washington
bonsoir bienvenue auteur de ce livre
camala Haris la pionnière de l'Amérique
c'est aux éditions plomb et Mathieu
croissand éditorialiste politique est
resté à mes côtés merci Mathieu dans
moins d'un an c'est le 5 novembre on
connaîtra le nom du nouveau président
américain qui sera sans doute un ancien
président annne desine ce match retour
Biden Trump est-ce qu'il est est-ce
qu'il est
obligatoire est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on
peut y échapper encore j'is dire çaager
que l'un d'entre eux tombe de l'escalier
et ok d'accord on est à ce niveau de
probabilité oui de même les sondages
sont des sondages nationaux ça ne veut
pas dire grand-chose puisqu'on sait que
ça va se jouer dans 3 qu hectares à
10000 voix c'était 10000 voix en Arizona
en 2020 c'était 20000 voix en 2016 donc
euh tout ce qu'on sait c'est que
personne ne veut de ce match ni les
républicains sauf les 30 % de fanatiques
Maga chapeau rouge et cetera et du côté
démocrate bien qu'il n'y ait pas de
primaire il y a quand même le Kennedy il
y a un indépendant et il y a une
écologiste celle qui a posé des petits
problèmes en 2016 et puis surtout il y a
des voix Axel rod vous vous rappelez
c'était le conseiller spécial de d'Obama
mais il dit bah peut-être que Biden
c'est pas le bon choix qu'il faudrait
passer à autre chose il y a de temps en
temps des des éeditos dans le Washington
Post qui se disent ben enfin quand même
il y a peut-être d'autres candidats un
peu plus jeunes parce que le danger
c'est Nicki est elle est en train de
elle présente bien elle n'est pas
radicale et si elle réussissait à battre
Trump on va voir ce qui se passe dans le
New Hampshire il est possible qu'elle
arrive en première position vous dites
que Donal Trump n'est pas sûr d'obtenir
l'inestiture républicaine bah c'est
moins sûr qu'il y a un mois disons mais
si ncky est investi par le Parti
républicain alors là les démocrates
peuvent mettre la clé sous le paillasson
Alex Pichard l'équipe de Joe Biden elle
souhaitait d'une certaine façon ce match
retour face à à Donald Trump est-ce
qu'elle déchante devant les bons
sondages de de l'ancien président
républicain al oui il y a effectivement
le risque de ce match retour et que la
victoire soit à nouveau emporté par
Donald Trump sachant que Donald Trump
profite enfin en tout cas les les
républicains profitent du système
électoral américain puisqueil il a
tendance à favoriser plutôt les petits
États qui votent massivement en faveur
des présidents républicains donc
effectivement afin que Joe Biden gagne
il faudra que tout l'électorat qui est
très volatile des démocrates se mobilise
ce qui n'a pas été le cas en 2016 est ce
qui a donné la victoire à Donald Trump
est-ce qu'il pourrait ne pas se
renouveler en l'année prochaine du fait
de certaines politiques et prises de
positionition de Joe Biden qui ont été
perçus comme n'allant pas suffisamment
loin notamment dans ses politiques
environnementales dans sa protection de
la jeunesse dans sa défense par exemple
des minorités ethniques quel électorat
il a plutôt perdu si l'on en croit les
sages plutôt les jeunes plutôt les
jeunes et ça se traduit à nouveau par
exemple sur ses prises de position
vis-à-vis d'Israël la jeunesse est
davantage porté sur un soutien plus
modéré ou en tout cas plus affirmé à la
cause palestinienne et ça ça se ressent
sur les campus et notamment du fait que
cette en fait cette cette cette ce
soutien à à la Palestine se se double en
fait d'un soutien aussi à la cause black
Liv matter souvent donc en fait il y a
un package qui est un peu plus tard sur
sur l'influence pardon n interromp du
confit au Proche Orient sur sur cette
campagne présidentielle il faut parler
de l'âge du capitaine quand même Armel
charier est-ce que c'est le principal
handicap ou défaut de Joe Biden
aujourd'hui et puis surtout est-ce que
en inter ça s'exprime de plus en plus à
l'intérieur du parti démocrate oui il
faut forcément parler de son âge parce
que 80 ans c'est pas du tout anodin
sachant que déjà quand il avait été élu
on s'était posé la question de savoir si
la vice-présidente était à ce point
importante parce que peut-être qu'elle
allait devoir le remplacer pendant son
élection enfin son son son mandat qui
est de 4 ans et que derrière on a
évidemment en tête tous les aements
qu'il a pu avoir quand on a vu un geste
un peu déplacé un mot qui ne
correspondait pas à la réalité une gaffe
qui avait été marqué un prompteur qui
avait été mal lu parce qu'on lait même
ce qui était à noté dessus donc
forcément ça veut dire qu'on repart avec
cette personneel donc ça c'est j'allais
dire une question physique qui forcément
pèse à l'intérieur du parti démocrate
maintenant à partir de moment donné où
un président est en campagne on ne va
pas le contrarier on ne va pas le
contredire la grande question finalement
c'était que est-ce que Joe Biden pouvait
se dire qu'il allait faire un mandat et
ne pas dire qu'il allait se représenter
par dans ce il j été créd l'urait jamais
suivi dans la logiqueélection américain
on serait dit on va soutenir celui qui
va le remplacer mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui il était pardon
interrompe presque obligé de se
représenter pour faire un premier mandat
efficace quoi ou a priori oui a priori
oui après on est pas on peut avoir des
gens qui vont se positionner en étant
des présidents de transition vous pouvez
avoir quelqu'un qui va avoir cette
logique là mais finalement on se rend
compte que une fois que vous êtes passé
dans le pris du pouvoir vous navez
jamais envie de le lâcher au final vous
avez toujours les mains dans le camboui
vous avez toujours effectivement des
rapports et c'est vrai que oui on le
voit partout mais c'est vrai que la
question la plus fondamentale
aujourd'hui elle se pose par rapport à
la jeunesse on n'imagine pas les
États-Unis avec un président avec des
présidents parce que la question se pose
aussi pour Donald Trump 77 ans avec des
présidents aussi âgés et finalement ce
pay la modité de dynamis àir raison ou
d'énergie que justement est-ce que la
question c'est l'âge ou la santé et si
c'est la santé quelle est la santé de
Joe
Biden qui veut répondre à ça allez-y
d'après les docteurs les médecins de la
de la Maison Blanche sa santé n'est pas
n'est pas un sujet en tous les cas alors
nous on sait en France que il faut pas
forcément croire les bulletins médicaux
des présidents m mais j'aimerais aussi
évoquer la santé de Donald Trump en fait
qui est pas meilleure on l'a vu
notamment durant des meetings prononcer
parfois des choses qui n'avaient pas de
sens confondre des pays à un moment
donné il a dit il faut que les
républicains mangent les jeunes donc il
a répété à plusieurs reprises donc en
fait il y a il y a beaucoup de d'indices
qui montrent il y a un FA indice qui
montre que la santé mentale de Donald
Trump n'est pas n'est pas aussi aussi
fluide et aussi aussi aussi forte qu'on
pourrait l'imaginer j'ai envie dire
pauvre électeur américain qui se
retrouve face à cette alternative
Olivier pyon si l'élection avait lieu
cette semaine si j'en crois les les
sondages Joe Biden perdrait sans doute
dans ce qu'on appelle les états pivots
les swing state c'est ce qui c'est ce
qui se profile à
l'horizon alors il faut toujours être
très prudent parce que comme cela a été
rappelé on a surtout des son sondage à
l'échelon national ce qui aux États-Unis
ne signifie pas grand-chose de sur quoi
on est à un peu moins d'un an de la
campagne présidentielle donc il faut
toujours prendre les les sondages à
l'échelon national de manière
extrêmement
prudente Joe Biden avait réussi quelque
chose d'absolument remarquable en 2020
c'est qu'il avait arraché une petite
partie mais une partie suffisante pour
gagner du petit électorat paupérisé
blanc dans ce qu'on appelle les swing
States en particulier en pyvanier dans
le Wisconsin cet électorat qui avait
voté Donald Trump en 2016 et qui s'était
tourné vers Joe Biden en 2020 cet
électorat là pour l'instant il semble on
va mettre des guillemets absolument
partout il semble perdu pour Joe Biden
en tout cas il est en pleine
introspection et l'enjeu l'un des enjeux
en tout cas de cette campagne il y aura
aussi le vote des femmes qui va être
extrêmement important mais le vote de
cette de cette petite frangeche de la
population blanche paupérisée des zones
désindustrialisées des États-Unis
avaient incontestablement été l'une des
clés de la victoire de Joe Biden et
aujourd'hui elle ne semble plus vouloir
aller voter ça veut pas dire qu'elle
irait voter pour Donald Trump et en tout
cas elle n'irait pas on met encore du
conditionnel partout en faveur de Joe
Biden le deuxème gros élément c'est
effectivement le vote féminin qui a
permis en particulier aux démocrates de
bien résister fair bien mieux que
résister aux élections intermédiaires et
qui sont liés effectivement à la
décision de la Cour suprême de remettre
en cause à l'échelon fédéral le droit à
l'avortement donc très difficile de
répondre à la question de savoir qui est
devant 48 44 pour l'instant entre les
deux candidats mais c'est ça ne veut pas
dire grand-chose un petit élément quand
même dans les deux premiers états de la
primaire c'est-àdire le newampchur et
l'owa Donald Trump semble légèrement
devant on va voir ce que ça va donner
sachant que du côté démocrate de fait il
y a pas de primaire puisqu'il y a pas
d'autrees candidat que Joe Biden
le le camp démocrate le camp Joe Biden
rappelle que 10 mois ou un an avant les
élections de mi-mandat par de la même
façon on prévoyait une bésina pour pour
les démocrates et finalement ils ont
bien résisté qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
c'est une espèce de réflexe antitrump
qui qui joue qui pourrait jouer
peut-être pas seulement antitrump mais
c'est ce qui s'est passé aussi pour les
élections qui viennent d'avoir lieu ou
en particulier en Virginie le le Congrès
local est maintenant gouverné par les
démocrates de façon à permettre des
contrepouir voir par rapport au
gouverneur qui est républicain ce que
sans doute les démocrates espèrent c'est
qu'il se passe en 2024 ce qui s'est
passé en 2022 et récemment en 2023
c'estàdire qu'au moment de décider
d'aller voter et de mettre le bulletin
les électeurs se rendent compte que ce
qui est en jeu c'est beaucoup plus que
Biden c'est peut-être le choix de la
démocratie plutôt que l'autocratie parce
que quand même on est en train de parler
de ce que va faire de ce que ferait
Donald Trump s'il était réélu abuser des
pouvoirs de l'exécutif faire des
représailles en en en instrumentalisant
le département de la Justice et les
poursuites contre tous ceux qui ont osé
lui
résister et puis surtout il commence à
rentrer un tout petit peu dans l'esprit
des indépendants des femmes cette
attaque systématiqu contre les droits
les libertés alors il y a eu
l'avortement mais il y a aussi tout ce
qui est fait par les républicains contre
le droit de vote des radiations des
suppression de bureau de vote qui comme
par hasard nuisent aux minorités qui ne
peuvent pas aller voter sauf en allant à
5 kmvec et donc il y a une certaine
prise de conscience l'avortement étant
un morceau idéalement il faudrait que
dans les états pivots il y ait un
référendum d'avortement parce que c'est
ça qui amènerait tout le monde à voter
parce que ce qui est important c'est que
même chez les républicain et pas
seulement les femmes les hommes
républicains aussi il y a 60 % qui
veulent garder un droit à l'avortement
d'au moins sorganiser ça quand vous
dites ça c'est c'est c'est hypothétique
où on peut rajouter au au scrutin du du
5 novembre prochain un référendum sur
laav les États de l'Ouest ont la
possibilité d'avoir ce qu'on appelle les
référendum d'initiative directe et dans
la risona par exemple ils sont en train
d'essayer de collecter les signatures
c'est comme ça que ça marche pour que un
texte figure sur le bulletin du mois de
novembre disant que les électeurs
veulent un droit alors dans certains
états c'est un droit constitutionnel à
ajouter dans la Constitution dans autres
c'est simplement un droit législatif
mais ça on s'en est rendu compte en 2023
c'est un excellent argument pour amener
les électeurs à aller voter sauf que
tous les états pivots n'ont pas cette
possibilité par exemple ça n'existe pas
en Pennsylvanie et puis c'est pas si
facile de collecter parce que dans les
états dirigés par les républicains il se
débrouillent pour changer les règles ou
pour faire invalider les signatures donc
et c'est quand même globalement il y a
beaucoup desélecteurs qui se rendent
compte que les républicains malgré tout
ce qu'ils disent agissent contre les
intérêts de l'Amérique moyenne alors on
parlait de et vous nous citiez certaines
gaffes on va dire de
Joe Biden la dernière date mais était-ce
une gaff tiens on va on va en débattre
c'était lors de cette conférence de
presse qui suit sa rencontre avec sin
ping un journaliste lui demande s'il
considère toujours le président chinois
comme un dictateur regardez sa réponse
et puis on vous propose à de l'autre
côté de l'écran la réaction dépité du
secrétaire d'État l'équivalent du
ministre des Affaires étrangères Anthony
blinken
regardez après aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous qualifieriez toujours le président
XI de
dictateur et bien oui c'est le cas c'est
un dictateur dans le sens où voilà un
homme qui dirige un pays un pays
communiste qui repose sur une forme de
gouvernement totalement différente de la
nôtre Anthony blincol qui sait qu'il va
devoir désamorcer derrière ça explique
certainement cette crimace de de dépit
d'ailleurs Pékin immédiatement dénonce
un discours je les cite extrêmement
erroné une manipulation politique
irresponsable Armel charier est-ce que
c'est forcément une bourde non je pense
que là en l'occurrence il a dit ce qu'il
pensait effectivement il a souvent
répété il a rappelé aussi que la Chine
était quand même l'ennemi et que même si
ils ont eu 4 heures de discussion à San
Francisco on se retrouver quand même
dans une situation où ce sont deux
personnes qui ne s'entendent pas et qui
ne s'apprécient pas et en plus il y a
certainement une vision complètement
différente des États-Unis euh de cette
façon de travailler de la Chine qu'il
juge effectivement dictatoriale mais
c'est aussi une qualité de pouvoir quand
il disent cela c'est parce qu'il sait
aussi qu'il va avoir des personnes qui
font se rallier à son point de vue il
parle aussi à une lge de l'ctor amériain
a absolument ou dans ce caslà il définit
quel est l'adversaire et quel est la la
marge de manœuvre le problème c'est
qu'effectivement quand on est président
à ce niveau-là on attend généralement
des personnes qui elles soient rondes et
puis on attend ces termes là ou ces
terminologie de la part de conseiller ou
alors justement quand on est en des
négociations et que du coup il faut
quelqu'un qui parle de cette manière là
et on voit bien que le décalage avec
Anthony blinen qui qui montre bien que
la le diplomate américain n' va pas dans
cette direction montre un désaccord qui
n'est pas forcément toujours de bonne à
loi ou ou ou peut-être que aussi on on
aurait imaginé ces mots-l dans la bouche
d'un Donald Trump Alexis B est-ce que
c'est pas ce à quoi on est en train
d'assister c'est un Joe Bindon qui se
trumpise aussi dans sa dans dans sa
campagne présidentielle dans sa façon un
peu binaire de présenter les arguments
alors je pense qu'il y a deux choses
d'une part Donald Trump à mon avis
naurait jamais prononcé ce mot parce que
Donald Trump vous culte en fait aux
hommes forts donc il a il a il a je me
souviens qu'il avait qualifié Poutine de
génie donc il aime les hommes forts que
ce soit bolsonaro Poutine ou son
homologue chinois il il ne s'adonne
jamais à l'insulte concernant Joe Biden
je pense que il il est conscient qu'il y
a un consensus en fait sur la sur la
Chine que ce soit dans la population
américaine ou au Congrès les les
républicains et démocrates sont d'accord
pour qualifier en fait ce régime de
dictatorial donc ilait pas pas grand
chose à perdre à mon avis ça a été
plutôt bien perçu parce que c'est
justement ça ça ravive en fait ça
galvanise les Américains autour d'un
ennemi commun alors je je je repose la
même question mais à vous Olivier piton
est-ce que la la la campagne en général
passe elle se trumpise vous voyez ce que
je veux dire c'est nous ce sentiment
qu'on a parfois vu d'ici peut-être un
peu au teint à la française voyez que la
campagne elle est au ras des pacret aux
États-Unis pas encore pas encore elle ne
devrait pas tarder à l'ê mais très
honnêtement pas encore tout simplement
parce que
chaque probable concurrent que ce soit
Donald Trump ou Joe Biden est pour
l'instant dans son couloir Donald Trump
évite soigneusement pour l'instant de
participer au débat des républicains et
donc d'une certaine manière les attaques
qui sont faites contre lui à part l'un
des candidats Chris chrisy qui est le
plus virulent contre Donald Trump passe
plutôt de manière
relativement simplement on n'est pas
véritablement encore dans une vraie une
vraie une vraie comment dirais-je une
vraie campagne trumpiste comme vous
comme vous auriez pu le dire maintenant
pour revenir sur sur ce qui a été dit
concernant concernant le qualificatif de
dictateur il y a effectivement comme
cela a été dit aux États-Unis depuis
toujours une un consensus total sur le
fait que oui un régime communiste est
forcément un régime dictatorial et que
qualifier le premier secrétaire du Parti
communiste chinois de dictateur n'est
absolument pas un débat ça n'est pas du
trumpisme c'est simplement la
réaffirmation d'une position profonde
des États-Unis que ce soit du côté des
démocrates ou du côté des républicaines
considérer qu'effectivement la Chine
n'est pas une démocratie et Joe Biden a
marqué des points à mon avis en le
disant clairement et j'iraai même plus
loin s'il avait eu 45 ans on ne se
serait jamais posé la question de savoir
s'il avait eu raison de qualifier X
jinpin de dictateur ou pas on se pose la
question parce que le fonctionnaire qui
est Anthony blinken a réagi de cette
manière- làà mais c'est le rôle du
fonctionnaire de tenter du diplomate
d'essayer d'arrondir les angles le rôle
du politique c'est de dire les choses
clairement et en l'occurrence je pense
que Joe Biden a marqué des points en
tout cas il a réaffirmé la position
claire de l'Amérique sur ce qu'est le
premier secrétaire du Parti communiste
chinois Anne desine Joy vous étiez pas
du tout d'accord avec moi sur le le
niveau de la campagne oui moi je ne
pense pas qu'il y ait de trempisation et
donc Jo Biden les fait à dessin ou non
c'est c'est important effectivement
d'essayer de de rassembler parce que
c'est un des rares points sur lesquels
les républicains et les démocrates sont
d'accord
et Joe Biden d'abord n'est pas revenu
sur les mesure de Donald Trump
concernant la Chine faut quand même se
rappeler que dès Obama il y a eu ce
désir cette prise de conscience que
l'adversaire c'était la Chine et ce
fameux pivot sur l'Asie de nouveau Biden
a essayé sauf que il est empêtré avec
l'Ukraine et maintenant avec le conflit
israélien à Gaza et que il va bien avoir
besoin que des textes soient adoptés
donc là on en a pas beaucoup parlé en
France mais il y a un mois environ il a
durci les mesure de contrôle des
exportations sur le matière sur le les
domaines des hautes technologies en
particulier les chips les
semiconducteurs merci les
semiconducteurs de haut niveau et a pris
d'autres règles pour éviter que ces
fameuses règles celles qui ont été
prises l'année dernière en octobre 2022
ne soit tourné parce qu'il a des
compagnies des sociétés américaines
commevidia qui disent ah oui ce matériel
ne peut pas pasêtre exporter donc moi je
vais faire un autre semi-conducteur un
petit peu moins puissant un petit peu
moins et cetera et l'export ou bien
l'exporter à des pays qui ne sont pas
dans la liste pay donc donc il a durci
il a durci ce texte oui il a durci le
texte parce que le le le vrai rival
c'est quand même la Chine alors il se
trouve que là il est occupé à faire
d'autres choses en Ukraine et à Gaza
mais le le vrai problème pour les
États-Unis c'est cette rivalité avec la
Chine qui est devenue dictatoriale donc
c'est bien de le dire allez mais moi je
remépétais en Cuse le terme dictateur je
pense que tout le monde autour de cette
table est à peu près d'accord c'est la
réaction de blinken qui qui qui suscite
évidemment ce questionnement je propose
à Steve Jourdain de nous rejoindre sur
ce plateau parce que vous avez les uns
et les autres évoqué le le le le proche
orient rebonsoir Steve évidemment on va
donc à moins d'un an je le rappelle de
cette présidentielle vous parlez d'une
zone de turbulence pour Joe Biden à
cause de ce conflit Israël Hamas oui Joe
Biden a parfois été décrit comme le
premier président américain siionist sa
proximité avec Israël elle remonte dans
les années 70 alors qu'il était encore
sénateur et a eu déut il y a eu débat
dans sa relation avec Benyamin Nanou
Premier ministre israélien depuis le 7
octobre il affiche un soutien déterminé
à l'État hébreu dans sa guerre contre le
Hamas ce weekend dans les pages du
Washington Post il persiste signe et
signe il signe même de sa main puisque
il a rédigé un article d'opinion qu'on
va voir on y lit la chose suivante aussi
longtemps que le Hamas s'accroche à son
éidologie de destruction un cess le feu
n'est pas la paix pour les membres du
Hamas chaque cess le feu est un moment
utilisé pour reconstituer le ST le stock
de roquett repositionner des combattants
et recommencer les tueres en attaquant à
nouveau des innocents pas de cesser le
feu donc à l'ordre du jour à la Maison
Blanche mais simplement une pause
humanitaire réclamée au gouvernement
israélien pour protéger les civils à
Gaza et on l'a évoqué rapidement tout à
l'heure cette ligne elle provoque des
critiques dans son propre camp dans le
camp démocrate effectivement on va voir
ces images mercredi dernier d'une
manifestation propalestinienne organisée
devant le siège du parti démocrate c'est
à Washington une centaines de
manifestants ont bloqué les accès des
heures ont éclaté avec la police à
l'initiative de ce
coup de force de groupes notamment de
militants Juifs issus de la gauche
radicale à priori des alliés historiques
du Parti démocrate il demande un cesser
le feu immédiat à Gaza message passé à
Joe Biden c'est très clair change ta
politique au Proche Orient si tu veux
être réélu l'année prochaine et cette
remise en cause de la politique de de
Joe Biden Prochant est-ce qu'elle a
est-ce qu'on la retrouve dans les
sondages on va voir ce dernier sondage
NBC paru ce weekend qui a été conduit
entre le 10 et le 14 novembre soit un
mois après l'attaque du Hamas contre
Israël seulement la moitié la moitié des
démocrates approuvent la politique
étrangère de Biden 51 % l'action du
président dans le conflit Israël Hamas
est rejeté par 41 % sans surprise on
trouve seulement 31 % et 22 %
d'probation chez les électeurs
indépendants et républicains bon vu
comme ça on pourrait se dire que la
politique étrangère de Biden au Proche
Orient est largement rejetée par une
majorité d'Américains c'est pas faux
mais quand on demande aux Américains ce
qu'ils pensent du conflit Israël Hamas
on va voir ces chiffres une majorité des
sondés 47 % estime qu'Israël se défend
légitimement et que ses actions
militaires à Gaza sont justifié 30 %
pensent qu'Israël va trop loin 21 %
disent ne pas avoir d'opignion dernier
chiffres intéressant on va le voir une
grande majorité des Américains
soutiennent l'aide militaire envoyé à
Israël 55 % on rappelle que chaque année
les États-Unis donnent 3,8 8 milliards
de dollars d'IDE à Israël et que Joe
Biden a promis d'aller beaucoup plus
loin il vou faire x 7 cet argent c'est
l'argent des contri des contribuables ça
va compter forcément dans la course à la
Maison Blanche merci beaucoup Steve
Jourdain Armen charier information en
cette fin d'après-midi lors d'une
cérémonie à la Maison Blanche question
posée par un un journaliste concernant
les otages un accord est-il proche
réponse lapidaire de du président
américain Joe Biden je crois est-ce
qu'il y a là un enjeu vraiment important
pour Joe Biden dans le cadre de cette
campagne présidentielle au-delà
évidemment du du sort des otages et de
leur et de leur vie c'est certainement
pas l'enjeu numéro
1 mais ça reste la porte de sortie pour
l'instant au niveau des Américains euh
pour un peu lever la main de Mami
netaniamu dans la guerre qu'il est en
train de mener sur Gaza et si vous avez
à un moment donné des sorties d'otage
même si ce ne sera pas tous les otages
même si on est sur 50 otages à priori
dont on parle dont on on sait pas si du
coup c'est exactement ce que a
aujourd'hui le Hamas à disposition comme
otage ou s'il en a encore un peu plus ou
sil sont dans d'autres groupes on on n
sait rien mais c'est vrai que il y a une
focalisation des États-Unis comme
d'autres pays surtout qu'il y a des
binationaux donc cette question là elle
est encore plus importante pour un
président américain à partir du moment
donné où il y a une sortie d'otage ça
veut dire que il peut demander à
Benjamin
netanahou de non pas d'arrêter la guerre
parce que les Israéliens n'arrêt on pas
la guerre mais de lever un peu le ma la
main et de dire on peut dans ces cas-là
regarder un peu au niveau de la
population palestinienne et vous avez vu
qu'il ne veut absolument pas réarmer le
Hamas il fait très attention pas de
cesser de feu c'est toute la complexité
aujourd'hui oui Alexis Pichard vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure mais que
pèse le au sein du parti
démocrate ceux qui reprochent justement
à Joe Biden une politique trop sioniste
vous parliez des jeunes sur certains
campus qu'est-ce qui pèse au sein de ce
parti mais les jeunes constituent quand
même même une partie importante du du
parti du parti républicain du Parti
démocrate aujourd'hui on voit que les
les campus commencent un peu à
s'embraser sur cette question de du
soutien des États-Unis à Israël et en
revanche j'aimerais bien revenir aussi
sur le le positionnement proisraélien de
de Joe Biden qui n'est à à mon sens qui
est bien plus modéré sur cette question
que son prédécesseur Joe Biden est
quelqu'un qui a servi durant les 8
années de de mandature d'Obama qui était
assez méfiant vis-à-vis du pouvoir
israélien il a il me semble dénoncé hier
ou avant-hier l'Éc israélienne en
sjordanie et surtout il a aussi
renégocié le traité enfin l'accord
d'Abraham qui ayant été qui avait été
passé par par Donald Trump pour
normaliser les relations entre Israël et
et les pays du monde arabe en intégrant
la Palestine au processus de discussion
donc pour moi c'est quelqu'un c'est un
président quand même qui qui prône une
solution à deux états ce qui n'est pas
du tout le cas de Donald Trump et en
cela à mon avis il est bien plus modéré
sur la question que que ce qu'on
pourrait croire et alors on peut poser
la question dans l'autre sens là je
posais la la question de on va dire de
d'un courant euh plutôt à gauche du
parti démocrate proalestinien est-ce que
à l'inverse andésine euh un des
contributeurs proisraël pèse lourd dans
le financement de la campagne Joe Bayen
mais peut-être aussi d'ailleurs de celle
de de Donald Trump et ça on sait que voà
évidemment c'est encore plus aux
États-Unis qui ailleurs le le le le ner
de la guerre et donc ils doivent l'un et
l'autre forcément tenir compte de ça
alors c'est un paradoxe parce que les
les Juifs aux États-Unis ont tendance à
voter démocrate ou mais le gros lobby
IPAC qui défend systématiquement les
politiques d'Israël est soutenue par les
républicains et par les évangéliques h
ouis et la force derrière Israël et donc
si Trump était réélu immédiatement ce
serait de nouveau une politique 100 %
Israël ce sont les évangéliques qui qui
à la limite sont beaucoup plus
extrémistes que les Israéliens eux-mêmes
et que les juifs américains donc nous
sommes dans cette situation en terme de
de financement de toute façon ce qui va
se passer dans les états pivots c'est
que ce sont des des des milliardaires
qui vont donner à des groupes 501 donc
on saura pas exactement qui a donné quoi
avec un déferlement de publicité
négative donc par exemple si on est à
minneéapolis où il y a une population
musulmane d'origine musulmane qui est
très choquée parce qu'elle jugeêtre une
attitude trop pro israélienne de Joe
Biden il va y avoir des publicités B
sonongère ou non puisqueavec le premier
amendement on peut dire tout était
n'importe quoi contre Joe Biden c'est
c'est ça un petit peu la situation
Olivier piton est-ce que c'est alors on
est encore une fois on est parce que
c'est dans un an mais est-ce que cette
élection américaine peut plus se jouer
sur les questions de politique
internationale que les que les
précédentes probablement pas mais le
conflit israëlo-palestinien est un
contestablement un un un problème pour
le camp démocrate parce que comme cela a
été dit euh il a tendance à
fracturer le camp démocrate en deux donc
en résumé ce qui a été dit était très
juste c'estàdire que Donald Trump avait
montré une une une volonté d'alliance en
particulier avec Israël mais surtout
avec Benjamin nitanahou c'estàdire qu'il
y avait vraiment une sorte de de mano à
mano entre les deux hommes qui a qui a
par je dirais par par par réaction créé
un certain nombre de dissension du côté
du Parti démocrate qui ne voulait pas
passer pour le parti qui était en faveur
de netanyiaù et lorsque Joe Biden est
est arrivé au pouvoir en dépit de toute
la bonne volonté de netanah pour tenter
de de de de resserrer les liens avec Joe
Biden incontestablement il s'est passé
quelque chose c'està-dire que cette
espèce d'uni d'unanimisme américain en
faveur de l'État d'Israël c'est quand
même un tout petit peu fissuré premier
élément deuxème élément comme cela a été
dit également et et je m'en rends compte
ici puisque y compris dans des petites
universités on a des manifestation en
faveur de Gaza pas en faveur du Hamas
mais en faveur de Gaza et des droits des
Palestiniens ce qui était pas le cas par
exemple exemple pour le conflit
ukrainien là on a des manifestations un
peu partout c'est que une partie de
l'électorat en particulier l'électorat
jeunes étudiants
urbains éduqués des démocrates a
tendance à reprocher à Joe Biden d'être
entre guillemets trop pro israélien
comment ça va se concrétiser dans le
vote on ne le sait pas ce que sera la
situation au ProcheOrient au moment des
élections ne le sait pas mais
incontestablement ça n'est pas une bonne
nouvelle pour un Joe Biden qui t une
position qui tente à tenir une position
traditionnelle des États-Unis de
soutient à Israël mais une partie de son
électorat en particulier le plus jeune
qui tente effectivement à considérer
qu'il est trop en faveur d'Israël c'est
un problème que les républicains ne
connaissent pas on va voir que le le
trumpisme peut également s'exporter
Mathieu avec cette mauvaise nouvelle
pour Joe Biden la nuit dernière en
Argentine oui avec l'élection de ravier
may qu'on qualifie d'ultralibéral de
populiste de nationaliste de
conservateur d'extrême droite lui-même
se qualifie F d'anarco capitaliste bref
vous avez compris les adjectifs vari
sauf un surnom sur lequel tout le monde
est d'accord c'est le Trump de la pampa
alors Donald Trump lui-même n'a
d'ailleurs pas attendu les résultats
officiels pour féliciter ravier my je
suis très fier de toi a-til écrit sur
son réseau social tu vas transformer ton
pays et faire de la de l'Argentine à
nouveau un grand pays Argentina make
Argentina great again si j'ose dire sur
voilà sur le modèle de son
alors diplomatie oblige l'administration
blinken a elle aussi félicité le nouvel
élu l'administration Biden pardon par la
voix du sec du secrétaire d'État Anthony
blinken qui lui voit dans cette élection
le témoignage des institutions
électorales et démocratiques de
l'Argentine en gros service minimum oui
quels sont les points communs de ravier
my avec Donald Trump un passé d'homme
d'affair la critique de la caste
politique des dérapages voire des
insultes verbal il pourfend comme Donald
Trump la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique he puisqu'il estime qu'
entreprise a le droit de polluer au nom
de la création de richesse il dénonce le
droit à l'avortement il défend le port
d'armes mais la comparaison s'arrête là
parce qu'en libertarien convaincu il
défend le mariage gay la libéralisation
de la drogue et même l'immigration alors
là pour le coup c'est pas du tout Donald
Trump ouis que traduit son élection ben
qu'un pays en crise économique profonde
où des élites ont failli reste un
terreau fertile pour le populisme sans
surprise pas sûr cependant que la
méthode mil améliore la vie des
quotidienne des Argentins quand on voit
ce qu'a promis le candidat euh il faisit
campagne avec une tronçonneuse en disant
je vais couper dans toutes les dépenses
inutiles et les dépenses inutiles par
exemple l'éducation euh la culture la
protection sociale il prendent la fin du
PZO qui veut aligner enfin qui veut
remplacer par le dollar et non plus même
aligné comme c'était autrefois le cas la
fin des subventions une libéralisation
des prix bref une thérapie de choc mais
qui a réjoui Elon Musk tiens le revoilà
celui-là qui voit le signe que la
prospérité attend de nouveau l'Argentine
et puis une élection qui a aussi soulevé
l'enthousiasme du voisin brésilien
l'ancien président ident bolsonaro
l'espoir brille à nouveau en Amérique du
Sud a écrit l'ancien chef de l'État
brésilien d'extrême droite espérant que
ces bon vent atteindront bientôt le
Brésil et évidemment les États-Unis
évidemment on prolonge un peu cette
parenthèse sur l'Argentine Armel charier
est-ce qu'il a ravier m mené une
campagne à la Trump est-ce qu'on peut
dire ça alors je l'ai pas suivi avec
assiduité mais je pense que on est aussi
dans cette espèce de tournant où
aujourd'hui on a ces hommes forts qui se
mettent en sc de cette manière- là et
que Trump a libéré on l'avait vu avec le
Brésilien on voit de nouveau a libéré un
certain type de parole en plus on est
dans des pays on est en Amérique
centrale et Amérique du Sud où
classiquement soit vous aviez une gauche
révolutionnaire communistes qui s'étit
installé soit vous avez des appétits qui
étaient les appétits des grandes
familles avant très à droite et donc on
retrouve dans toute cette extrême droite
aussi tout ça qui est en train de
revenir et puis vous avez une espèce de
libérisation qui est en train de se
mettre en place ce qui va être
intéressant c'est que là on va être dans
les pays qui vont de nouveau parler de
nationalisme qui vont de nouveau parler
de protectionnisme et que ce à quoi je
pensais au moment où j'entendais c'est
que on est aussi dans des pays qui
maintenant sont aussi en train de
discuter avec Vladimir Poutine sont
aussi en train de discuter avec
shijinping sont aussi intéressés par
l'évolution justement des bricks
l'ouverture et cetera et que ça c'est
une aussi une gageure pour les
Américains et ça explique aussi pourquoi
est-ce que Biden doit passer 4 heures de
discussion avec P parce que d'un seul
coup s'invite le dossier du Proche
Orient qui n'avait jamais été là mais à
partir du moment donné où maintenant che
Jinping joue un rôle et que il dit ben
moi j'ai l'Arabie Saoudite l'Égypte les
Émirats arabes unis qui veulent
rejoindre l'extension des ça veut dire
quelque chose et on on voit bien toutes
C toutes ces difficultés que que doivent
aujourd'hui générai les Américains sur
la question israélienne par exemple
juste un mot mais c'est vrai que c'est
leur alliier classique traditionnel donc
il est pas question de le lâcher jamais
il ne sera question de le lâcher parce
que c'est leur seule entrée aujourd'hui
au Proche et au Moyen-Orient et que du
coup si les Américains sont pas derrière
Israël où est-ce qu'ils seront les
Américains dans ce monde complexe et
c'est là aussi où on voit une fracture
générationnelle c'est-à-dire que vous
avez une réflexion comme ça parce qu'on
a l'habitude du proche et du Moyen
Orient la jeunesse elle est pas comme ça
la jeunesse elle est aujourd'hui dans
des logiques qui sont des logiques de
décolonisation de wisme d'ouverture et
donc elle elle pense davantage droit
humain et elle pense aux Palestiniens et
à Gaza je vrais revenir à cette campagne
américain peut-être le climat de la
campagne avec un exemple en ce moment il
y a évidemment un bras de fer autour du
vote ouvrier Joe Biden était il y a 10
jours dans lilinois venait célébrer des
accords salariaux historiques dans le le
secteur de l'industrie automobile
écoutez ce qu'il dit enfin il prononce
même pas le le nom de Donald Trump
regardez mon prédécesseur le distingué
bref
lorsque mon prédécesseur était au
pouvoir six usines ont fermé dans tout
le pays des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois dans l'automobile ont été
perdus dans tout le pays et pour
couronner le tout il était prêt à
confier l'avenir des véhicules
électriques à la Chine il a déclaré si
l'Amérique investit dans des véhicules
électriques cela fera baisser les
salaires cela détruirait des emplois et
sonnerait le glas de l'industrie
automobile américaine comme presque tout
ce qu'il a dit il s'est
trompé vous interrogez pardon seulement
sur la forme ce ce signe de croix là
quand il ne prononce pas le nom de
Donald Trump c'est une façon de le
désigner comme le diable est-ce que
c'est nouveau dans sa campagne c'est une
nouvelle stratégie comment vous le
l'analyz c'est surprenant donc il fait
un petit peu il emprunte aux techniqu
théâtral de Trump hein il dit pas le nom
et mais quand même le signe de croix
j'étais un petit peu surprise mais sur
le fond il a raison et ce qui est
incroyable et on va voir dans un an si
finalement les électeurs comprennent que
les politiques économiques de
l'administration Biden fonctionnent
parce qu'il a quand même relancé la
machine il crée des emplois et 14
millions d'emplois créés depuis le début
de son mandat taux de chômage en octobre
3,9 % mais sauf que beaucoup d'électeurs
voient l'inflation qui a beaucoup baissé
et qui reste là sans sans voir les
bonnes choses donc il y a encore
quelques mois et peut-être il y aura une
au moment là encore de mettre le
bulletin dans l'urne sauf qu'ils mettent
pas un bulletin dans l'urne ils
remplissent et cetera mais au moment de
de voter cette prise de conscience qu'il
est vraiment pro ouvrier pro syndicat il
est quand même allé sur les piquets de
grève et cetera mais il y a beaucoup de
désinformation et le malheur c'est que
ce qu'il dit n'est entendu que par ceux
qui ont envie de l'entendre tous ces
gens qui sont pro Trump Maga et cetera
n'entendent jamais cela parce que ça
n'est pas sur leur réseau avec ses
bulles cognitives et cetera et et c'est
ça le vrai problème c'est quel type
d'information va pouvoir circul alors
qu'est-ce ce qu'ils entendent les les
les les partisans les soutiens de Donald
Trump évidemment c'est le candidat
républicain parlait d'inflation c'était
à l'occasion d'une visite à la frontière
mexicaine hier l'inflation détruit tout
dans tous les pays depuis des centaines
d'années l'inflation dévaste tout nous
connaissons la pire inflation depuis 72
ans au départ elle était causée par
l'énergie et maintenant elle est partout
Alexis Pichard le bilan économique de
Joe Biden alors effectivement vous nous
dites il est pas il est pas connu de
tous mais est-ce qu'on peut légitimement
dire qu'il est positif euh oui ben comme
vous l'avez rappelé le le le chômage est
toujours un niveau très très bas la
croissance je crois que pour cette année
elle 5 % au-delà de de la croissance
chinoise qu'on qu'on dont on disait
qu'elle dépasserait finalement les
États-Unis donc fin oui il a
l'inflation l'argument trum est- est-ce
qu' porte elle a quand même diminué ces
derniers mois euh mais mais
effectivement comme l'a dit andesine il
a quand même fait passer des textes de
loi importants le justement le texte
anti-inflation qui a passé l'an dernier
en fait qui est un texte écologiste
déguisé mais qui prendra effet dans
quelques dans quelques temps donc c'est
effectivement dur de vendre un texte de
loi qui n'aura d'effet notamment sur par
exemple la la chute du prix de
l'insuline c'est quelque chose qui va
être qui va être mise en application
dans quelques années donc c'est vrai que
c'est dur en fait de vendre de de de
récupérer les mérites d'un texte de loi
dont les effets ne seront sentis que
dans quelques que dans quelques temps et
pareil le le texte sur les
semiconducteurs qui a rapatrié la
production des semiconducteurs en aux
États-Unis n'aura d'effet que dans Bour
en fait donc c'est c'est très compliqué
de de faire voter des des des textes de
loi qui vont avoir des effets sur le
long terme et dans d'essayer de glaner
les bénéfices de manière un peu
anticipée an dés il y a quand même le
plan
d'infrastructure et là il y a quand même
des constructions de ponts de routes et
cetera dans un certain nombre d'États et
en particulier des états rouges des
états républicains d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce que les élus
républicains qui ont évidemment voté non
sont en train de dire regardez toutes
ces argent fédéral qui vient dans notre
état et là avec des créations d'emplois
peut-être que au bout d'un moment le le
message va percuter le message il est
aussi porté on a dit beaucoup de mal de
Kamala Haris qu'elle n'était pas très
bonne et cetera mais en ce moment elle
fait du porte à porte il y a pas d'autre
terme et elle se base sur le droit à
l'avortement les libertés et le droit de
vote et ça ça peut peut-être faire
contrepoid chez les jeunes les jeunes
ils ont d'un côté Gaza mais ils ont
aussi l'environnement le droit de vote
et l'avortement Olivier piton il y a il
y a un élément qu'on n pas
analysé les deux campagnes électorales
sont difficilement comparables parce que
celles de 2020 il y avait le covid et
donc la la pression sur Joe Biden était
physique hein on parle de de sa capacité
physique à tenir une campagne électorale
était pas la même est-ce que ça peut
jouer ça
euh oui ça peut jouer on se souvient
qu'en 2020 Joe Biden avait en gros était
resté dans le dlloware n'avait pas avait
réussi à éviter l'un des trois débats
contre Donald Trump en fait il devait y
en avoir trois il y en avait eu que deux
et il avait il avait déjà à ce moment-là
des problèmes de de de de d'appréciation
cognitive on va dire mais il avait
réussi habilement à les à les à les
déjoué si vous voulez par une espèce de
calendrier extrêmement bien tiré au cord
d'au et particulrement habile le
problème c'était l'avantage du covid si
je puis dire là il n'y aura pas
d'avantage de de covid en tout cas on
l'espère et donc la campagne risque
d'être effectivement aussi intense
qu'elle est habituellement à partir de
ce moment-là est-ce qu'il sera en mesure
de tenir euh la distance si c'était lui
qui effectivement mais là maintenant ça
paraît difficile pour lui de ne plus
l'être de ne plus être le candidat
démocrate on est trop proche du début
des primaires sera-t-il capable de mener
une année entière de campagne euh comme
il devrait pouvoir le faire c'est l'une
des questions effectivement que se
posent les observateurs américains il
faut se souvenir qu'à l'époque Donald
Trump enchaînnait entre deux voire trois
meetings par jour ce qui était une sorte
de de d'exploit physique et il y aura
forcément une comparaison avec Joe Biden
donc cet aspect- là vous avez tout à
fait raison va aussi jouer un point sur
ce qui a été dit juste avant c'est
effectivement assez désolant pour Joe
Biden qui a honnêtement un un bilan
économie tout à fait appréciable voire
même bon malheureusement la focalisation
se fait davantage sur l'apparence sur
son âge que sur ses réussites économi
qui sont absolument incontestables il
essae son équipe essaie de faire passer
le message pour l'instant il n'y arrive
pas on verra s'il y arrivera ce sera
aussi l'une des clés de la de la
campagne c'est de réussir à faire à
mettre en avant ces réussites
économiques qui sont à contestable merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je vais rappeler le titre de
vos livres andésine le les États-Unis et
la démocratie publié aux éditions
l'armatan et Olivier pyon camala Haris
la pionnière de l'Amérique publiée aux
édition plomb demain demain on sera au
salon des mires Porte de Versailles à
Paris pour une édition spéciale de sens
public et puis Notter que l'invité de la
matinale sera Dominique fort la ministre
déléguée chargé des collectivités
territoriales et de la ruralité belle
[Musique]
soirée